i am so honored that people have thought
to highlight
the work
not me but the work that i've been
trying to do at mit right um
and i think the work is the most
important thing to highlight so i want
that to be loud and clear um it's not
about me it's about the work and
the people
not one but the people there is no me
without us
austin not only demonstrates strong
leadership skills but he also
makes opportunities for others to
shine as
well seeing a need and creating space
for others
not only to be heard or to be seen but
also
discussing ways where we can elevate
one
another he was able to build a community
that was not only just an intellectual
community but also a community that felt
safe and that felt heard at the same
time
i can advocate support
highlight and help tell the stories of
those
who feel unseen and unheard and so
that's kind of the energy that i bring
to
the office in the classroom every day um
it is a hip-hop energy
it's it's about disruption it's about
making people think critically
i don't think anything i've done has
been
remarkable
i'm just trying to be remarkably human
oriented
interested in the welfare of the people
around me and i know
that when they're better
i'm better and when i'm better they're
better and then we'll all be better
[Music]
you